there are a lot of ways we can break
this movie down so let's start with the
opening credits they are a montage of
mysterious grungy images and subliminal
messages
many of these show preparations made by
the serial killer john doe such as him
throwing himself into books about the
seven deadly sins the christian
teachings upon which his crimes are
based detective somerset and mills
eventually use his library records to
track him down
there are also images of razer blades
and jon cutting the skin off of his
fingers which turns out to be part of
the reason that law enforcement is
unable to find any fingerprints at any
of his crime scenes or even while
searching his apartment
we haven't found a fingerprint yet um
you're right i don't believe you
keep looking the title sequence also
includes his dark room for developing
photos and his writing of personal
manifestos both part of his incredible
collection of
journals and photographic documentation
of his work which he expects to be
remembered and studied for years to come
[Music]
and what i've done is gonna be puzzled
over and studied
and followed
forever i think the same could be said
of david fincher's movie but that's
beside the point a behind-the-scenes
documentary shows how the art department
created hand-sewn notebooks and they
speak of wanting to nail the personality
of doe's penmanship
they wanted this kind of obsessive
quality to their hair and we see a
similar style of writing overlaid on top
of the title sequence some of these
messages only appear for as short as 1
24th of a second but once deciphered we
can use them to better understand some
of the hidden details in this film
so stick around to the end of this video
because i'll be unpacking everything
this video is sponsored by raycon
welcome to things you missed in today's
episode i'll be going over seven things
you might have missed in david fincher's
sophomore film
sevenan now you may be angrily typing
right now why aren't you starting with
his first film
alien cubed well i figure i'm gonna do
the alien franchise at some point and
when i do i'm gonna do them all together
so before i get to that there is no
shortage of excellent horror thriller
types in fincher's catalog and
7n is an ideal place to start you know
this isn't going to have a happy ending
let's get into the things you missed
[Music]
some of the messages that briefly flash
on screen during the title sequence look
to be alphanumeric codes
for example d35 comes up several times
and there's also a brief d36 another one
that comes up a couple of times is c24
but what do these strange codes
actually mean while there are a number
of possibilities i like to look at the
psychological battle between the
detectives and the killer that they're
trying to catch like a game of chess
in chess there are a number of
strategies called gambits simply put a
gambit is a calculated risk taken with
the hope that it will give the player
the upper hand
so i might allow my opponent to take one
of my pieces in order to ultimately get
the positioning that i want and get a
checkmate
if i accept this invitation i'll be
giving in to his intent
i can't allow this this humiliation
one famous instance of this is the
queen's gambit declined which is known
in the chess community as variation in
d35
there's also a similar variation known
as d36 c24
is another gambit known as the bishop's
opening if you think about it john doe's
strategy to get what he wants from mills
is basically a gambit
he willingly gives himself up to the
police in order to set things in motion
this forces the detectives into the
position he wants them in because they
have to take him outside of the city
limits to find the two bodies that he
supposedly hid out there and ultimately
it leads to a czech mate against
detective mills who can't restrain
himself after finding what john doe did
to his wife
after killing her he delivers her head
to the detectives inside of a box and by
doing so he completes his mission
she would be the sixth victim envy and
mills would take his revenge making john
doe the seventh victim
wrath john doe set up the pieces
perfectly and mills found himself to be
nothing more than a piece in his
masterful game of chess
the experienced detective somerset is
much better at not falling for john
doe's tricks than detective mills who
lets his emotions overtake him
causing him to make stupid moves perhaps
this is because somerset has some
experience
in the game of chess while mills is more
of a basketball guy basketball is also a
game that requires strategy
spacing and a good game plan but
basketball has a much higher pace of
play due to its 24 second shot clock
unlike chess a lot of moves need to be
made on the fly which
explains why mill's actions on the spot
can get him into a lot of trouble
leaving him as a vulnerable target for a
thoughtful calculating villain such as
john doe
think of mills like the j.r smith of
this movie
rebound goes to the cavs j.r smith
brings it back out
throws it a hill it is one of the most
brain-dead idiotic things that i've ever
witnessed right there are many scenes
that highlight how mills's impulsiveness
contrasts to somerset's guile like how
somerset does is studying with long
nights at the library while mills skims
the cliff's notes how somerset has
carefully thought about leaving his city
for 34 years while mills jumps to retin
apartment after five-minute tours with a
slimy realtor
soothing relaxing vibrating home
how mills recklessly runs into danger
after a suspect while somerset
asks around for a back exit and
ultimately how somerset is content with
capturing john doe and doesn't want to
play into his hands any further
while mills can't just let him sit
around in prison and is more inclined to
accept his offer and go out to find the
remaining two victims
full confession i'm in the differing
approaches from the two detectives are a
result of their circumstances which are
quite opposite of one another
in both basketball and chess opponents
have their own side
your teammate should be headed in the
same direction that you are but mills is
celebrating his first seven days on the
job while somerset is counting down his
last seven the movie shows us how their
experience dictates how they interact
with the city one of their first scenes
has them walking down the street
together the experienced summerset flows
seamlessly through the pedestrian
traffic while mills is bumping into
people and going around people he has a
lot to learn about his new environment
i've worked homicide five years not here
i understand that
well over the next seven days detectives
you'll do me the favor of remembering
that
as they investigate the first crime
scene the one that represents gluttony
somerset is focused in on the job
looking for clues but his partner is
making small talk and again
the way that the scene is presented says
more than the screenplay itself the
music almost overpowers the volume of
mill's frivolous comments like somerset
is trying to block out the distraction
with his focus
we see somerset do essentially the same
thing at home using his metronome to
help him get some sleep while horrible
things are happening just outside of his
walls
when i'm looking to drown out the noises
and distractions of the outside world i
turn to my raycon
everyday e25 earbuds these earbuds are
the best model yet and i can't tell you
how freeing it is to just link these
things up with my phone and move around
the house all day and not having to
worry about wires getting in my way or
getting tangled
or getting caught on something and
yanking them out of my ears you can just
drown out the sound of sirens gunshots
or
even your roommates and with six hours
of play time and more bass and a compact
noise isolating design
raycons are perfect for all your audio
listening needs click the link in the
description that's by recon dot com
slash cz's world to get 15 percent off
your order today
perhaps the biggest and most important
difference between detective somerset
and detective mills is highlighted in
this bar scene where somerset explains
why he's quitting and leaving the city
i just don't think i can continue to
live in a place that embraces
and nurtures apathy as if it was a
virtue
he's trying to warn the younger
detective that in this city not caring
is celebrated and he thinks that
attitude is the reason that people in
the community get involved with drugs
crime and abuse
love on the other hand takes effort and
work somerset admits that he's no better
than anyone else he's part of the
problem
because he often takes the easy route by
being apathetic but while he claims to
have this cynical view of himself and
his city his actions
suggest otherwise early on he requests
to be taken off the case because he
doesn't want to end his career on
something that'll just drag on and on
but his supervisor who he's worked for
for years doesn't buy his story
i don't think you're leaving half you
can't leave all this
you do this work you were made for it
and i don't think you can deny that
maybe i'm wrong somerset disagrees
however in that same scene he tells off
a maintenance man who's scraping the
detective name off the door
uh excuse me excuse me could you not do
that please
it's almost like a subconscious part of
him doesn't want his name to be removed
from that office despite his insistence
otherwise
i can't get involved but moments later
he walks past a banner
do you know what you've been getting
into are you positive maybe he does
maybe he doesn't but he does get more
and more involved as the case goes on
and i think he's very much aware of it
at the beginning of the movie he tells a
cab driver that he's on his way out
[Music]
suggesting that he no longer wants to be
involved with the city and the crime
that comes with it and of course his job
bringing those criminals to justice
going back to his line in the bar love
costs love takes effort and work but he
doesn't want to put in that effort
anymore but by the time the fifth murder
has taken place he's decided to stay on
to the end of the case
he has no real reason to do that other
than the fact that he cares about the
outcome
then at the end even after john doe gets
his way by putting mills wife's head in
a box causing mills to retaliate and
make jon the seventh and final victim
even after all of that hurt and
suffering it sounds like somerset is
still going to stay on
where are you gonna be
around ernest hemingway once wrote
the world is a fine place and worth
fighting for
i agree with the second part one of my
favorite movie quotes of all time and
seven also contains one of the better
movie villains of all time but you
probably won't see me doing an episode
of horror history on john doe
because the whole idea behind of his
character is that he doesn't really have
a history i already discussed the fact
that he's basically removed himself from
the crimes he committed by cutting the
skin off of his fingers the name john
doe is also kind of ironic for somerset
and mills because john doe is oftentimes
used as a placeholder name in the world
of law enforcement when a person's name
is unknown or needs to be concealed
there's also the fact that for the first
half of the movie we don't see john doe
then when we do see him he's just a
nondescript guy in a trench coat
great lengths are taken to preserve his
anonymity there's actually one exception
to this
after police discover the third victim
the one representing sloth a supposed
media photographer comes to get some
shots but if we look
very closely it's actually john doe
returning to the scene of the crime to
document what he had done
probably to add the images to his
notebooks on top of notebooks about his
work and the relation to the seven
deadly sins what he gets instead is a
very pissed off detective mills who
swats his camera and chases him away
this gives john doe the opportunity to
rile him up to test his restraints which
all plays into his plan to make him
commit the final murder to represent
wrath this is the reason he lets him
live during their next encounter when
mills chases him out of his apartment
building into an alley where john doe is
able to catch him by surprise and get
the upper hand
john's objective is to use his crimes to
teach the world of their sins
he had religious reasons behind what he
did and he felt that he had to do
something big to get the world's
attention
however he seemed to believe that he was
doing this entirely for the cause and
not at all to bring attention to himself
and that is what made him so difficult
to beat
despite being a criminal mastermind he
never acted like he was anything more
than just
another john doe now one of the images
that comes up near the end of
n would bring the movie full circle we
started with subliminal messages being
spliced in
and in the penultimate scene an image of
mills wife tracy appears for just one
frame director david fincher would bring
back the idea of splicing single frames
into movies for his 1999 film fight club
where one of the characters in the movie
literally does that
he had one part-time job as a
projectionist because it affords him
other interesting opportunities
like splicing single frames of
pornography in a family film
but fight club and his previous work the
1997 action film the game don't really
fit into the horror thriller genre for
that we have to skip ahead a few years
to 2002 for panic room so lock your
doors and join me for the next episode
of things you missed
and make sure you subscribe to cz's
world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we stay inside